Hello.
>> How you doing?
>> You all right?
>> Yeah, I'm pretty good.
>> So, you you mentioned earlier on about
uh the Injil. Do you know what's the
deal is?
>> Can you tell me?
>> Yes, why not? If you want to know
actually.
>> Yes, I would love to know.
>> Yeah, the Inil because I'm a researcher,
you know, and I do research actually and
I've been researching for the the
scripture major religion scripture.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh for a while actually. and uh about
the inje what in is so there's a lot of
verses there's some verses in the Bible
in the gospels actually is like uh
Jesus says the only one true God first
Jesus was preaching
montheism you know and uh
>> so Jesus's words are Jesus's words in
the Bible are the in
>> yeah some verses. Some verses, not all
the verses, some verses actually.
>> How do you know which verses are in the
angel and which ones aren't?
>> Because when Jesus talk about the
oneness of God, which is called he
mentioned earlier on,
>> that's not answering the question. How
do you how do you know that that's part
of the NGO and what isn't?
>> Exactly. That's what I'm saying, you
know, because the only one true God,
which is Jesus mentioned, the only one
true God is the father, you know, and
and uh there's some other
>> brother brother, I'm I'm asking a very
straightforward question, and you're not
answering it. Okay? I I don't know if uh
you understand what I'm asking, but I'm
I don't know how else to ask it. That's
the only way I know how to ask it. How
do you know that when Jesus says the one
true God is the father that that is in
the NGO and the other things that he
says like he is the son of God who came
down from heaven to die for our sins.
How do you know that that's not in the
NGO for example?
>> But you forgot like you know um
in the in the gospel Jesus been
mentioned eight times.
>> I'm going go ahead and give you one last
chance to answer the question that I
asked you. Yeah. one last chance. And if
you cannot answer this, my friend, cuz
you've been up here a few times before,
if you cannot answer this question, I
will be forced to ban you from having
trying to have a conversation with me
because you are incapable. You seem
incapable of engaging with the questions
and points raised to you. So I don't
want you to waste my time. I don't want
you to waste your own time or the
audience time watching. How do you know
what word the words that Jesus said are
in the injil and which words Jesus said
that are not in the how do you know
because in Islam Islam is a motism
like you know is oneness of God which is
all the prophet messenger they were all
preaching oneness of God you know same
as Jesus you know and we believe Jesus
was a Muslim
You know, and that's that's why like my
father greater than I my father greater
than all, you know, and I can't do
nothing. I can I can do
>> I'm going block you now. You're not even
welcome to watch my live streams. I do
not care about we believe. We believe.
Not interested in that. I'm not
interested in the we believe crew. Not
interested in the we believe script. I'm
only interested in what you know and
what you can prove. That's what I'm
interested in. Not we believe we believe
when Jesus says this is in the is in the
is in the jail in Jesus when Jesus
himself the father is greater than I.
The father is greater than all. The one
true God is the father. We believe in
we believe Jesus. We believe Jesus was
Muslim submitted himself. We believe to
one God and so some of the words of
Jesus
we believe in your Bible some of the
words of Jesus
is indeed you one God Muslim not
interested guys I'm not interested so
just to let you guys know when you come
up on the stage and the platform you
have a golden opportunity to speak
clearly and to speak with evidence and
to show us how and why you're saying
what you're saying. You believe what you
believe. You know what you know.
>> Okay.
>> Let's go ahead and uh get our next guest
up. Let's get Shaf Yaya up here.
[screaming]
>> I can hear your kid yelling. Sha.
>> Hey, no logic. How are you?
>> What's up, Swan? You good?
>> Yeah, I'm so I have a question. Last
time last last night I talked with Chris
and he provide me a a verse from the old
testament that God command to the Moses
to not take away anything from the book
nor adding some. So the Christian
brother he he told me to the trinitarian
people are idol worship. So what do you
think about this?
>> What do you think? Yes. I think it's
idulary to ask
a human.
>> Do you think it's idolatry to worship
God?
>> No. No, brother. To add more to add more
people with the uh God
>> to add more people.
>> It's mean if you if you believe on the
trinity like father, son and holy
spirit.
>> Mhm.
>> So so it's not a one person. God have a
no partner.
>> Yeah. We we agree that God has no
partners. Um the trinity doesn't teach
that god is partners. So the trinity
teaches that there's one god who just
happens to be multi-personal. There's no
other god who is a partner to him.
>> So you people believe there's a holy
spirit and Jesus they are not like they
are not three.
>> They're not three gods. No only three
persons.
>> Okay. So is the father is the Jesus?
>> When I say three persons what do you
understand when I say that?
>> No. Is the father is the Jesus?
>> No. When I say three persons, what do
you understand when I say that? When I
say three persons, what do you
understand when I say that?
>> When I say three persons, what do you
understand? When I say
>> when I say three persons,
>> when I say three persons, what do you
understand when I say that? I'm in I'm
inviting you right now.
>> I'm inviting you to step outside of your
mechanical programming
>> and to engage like a human being. Go
ahead and engage like you. You can do
it. You can do it. I promise you, Sha,
you can do it. Okay. You can do it.
>> So, what do you understand when I say
three persons? What do you understand by
that?
>> Like I I understand you you claiming
that the the Holy Spirit and the Jesus
Christ, they are not a separate
property.
>> What is a person?
>> A separate property is a person.
>> A separate property.
>> Yeah. What? What? What's a property?
Using words we don't know.
>> What do you think? You can explain. You
can explain me,
>> brother. No, just a No. I choose me,
man. I choose me. Oh my gosh, man. I
don't know. Maybe this is this is better
uh this is better, I guess, than
watching somebody yap, you know, with
big words that they don't know, but now
I'm experiencing it. [clears throat]
Goodness gracious. You guys are coached
to do the same thing, to think the same
way. It's amazing.
>> Yeah. Hello,
>> Jad. Welcome back.
>> Welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> Basically,
um, what's the topic though? Like, can I
ask a question or
>> you can ask me why I think Islam is
false?
>> Why is that?
>> Because it claims things that do not
exist like that are just wrong. So for
example, did you know that the Quran
claims that the previous scriptures, the
Torah, the Gospel, and the Psalms that
they mention the Quran itself? Not not
just mention Muhammad, but that the
Quran actually mentions I mean the
previous scriptures mention the Quran.
Did you know that? Did you know the
Quran says that?
>> Yeah, of course. Um it is a um criteria
for a Muslim if you like he's not a
Muslim, true Muslim if he does not
believe in the previous books and
revelations. No, I don't think you you
understood what I said. The Quran says
that the previous books mention the
Quran. They for they foretell the Quran
coming.
>> Well, there are many things that the
previous books mentioned, but they
mentioned that the coming of the of the
prophet himself, the last
>> I know you think that it mentions the
prophet coming. Did you know that the
Quran says that they mention the book
coming, the Quran coming? Did you know
that?
>> I think I'm not sure. Maybe I've heard
that before, but um right now at this at
this minute, I can't remember it.
>> Man, I couldn't believe it when I read
this. Let me see if I can uh 196. There
it is. 196. Thank you. I knew I wasn't
tripping. I was in the right chapter,
but I just didn't have the verses right.
All right. So, here it is. Yeah. So,
just to start with a little bit of
context, it says uh we'll start at 192,
I think. Yeah. And indeed the Quran is a
revelation of the Lord of the worlds.
And then verse 96 still talking about
the Quran says and indeed it is
mentioned in the scriptures of the
former peoples. So the Quran is
mentioned in the in the former
scriptures. Now I have never ever now
same thing about Muhammad but the Quran
>> is the uh verse on the chapter
>> chapter 26 a Ash ashur the poets chapter
verse 196 I can't believe it says the
Quran is mentioned in the previous
scriptures usually we hear that Muhammad
is mentioned in the previous scriptures
hardly do we ever get Muslims saying
that the Quran itself is mentioned
mentioned in the previous scriptures,
but there's a Quran verse that actually
says that and Muslims don't argue this.
Why don't you guys argue this? It's
because it doesn't exist. Well, um
certainly the teachings or many many
teachings in the Quran that they indeed
have been talked before in the in the
previous books. So for example um in the
Bible it says that if a woman fornicates
if she has um um like if she fornicates
with another guy outside their marriage
you should bring her kill her. Sorry my
bad and analy her in front of her in
front of her father's house. So the
Quran doesn't go that far.
>> So it does not say that you should analy
her. What what does this have to do with
what I'm my brother? I I And I really
want you to answer this because I'm not
asking this like as a rhetorical
question. Genuinely,
>> what did what you just said have to do
with what I have brought up to you?
>> Well, um my point being that some of the
teachings of the Quran now, they they
are the same teachings that that are
mentioned in the previous books.
>> Yeah. But what does that have to do with
what I brought to you? That the Quran
itself is mentioned in the previous
scriptures. Not similar laws, not
similar rulings or similar ideas, but
that the previous scriptures mention the
Quran. Do you do you see how what you
were saying doesn't touch what I was
asking about?
>> Yeah, I I I get what you're saying.
>> Okay. No doubt.
>> Do you have any ideas of where we can
find the Quran mentioned in the in the
previous scriptures?
>> Well, to be honest, um I haven't really
um gone so far to to see the tap of this
first because I think that would help
understanding the bigger picture. Okay,
let's go with um so here's Jalalain says
and it and truly it the illusion to the
Quran that would be revealed to Muhammad
is in the scriptures the books of the
ancients such as the Torah and the
Gospel. So that's Jalain. Here's
Ibikadir titled the Quran was mentioned
in the previous scriptures. He says,
"Allah says this Quran was mentioned and
referred to in the previous scriptures
that were left behind by their prophets
who [snorts] foretold it in ancient
times and more recently. Allah took a
covenant from them that they would
follow it and and the last of them stood
and addressed his people with the good
news of Ahmed." So obviously talk about
Jesus and then he quotes it. Remember
when Issa son of Miam said, "Oh children
of Israel, I am a messenger of Allah
unto you, confirming the Torah before
me, and give glad tidings of a messenger
to come after me whose name shall be
Ahmed." Zabor here refers to books.
Okay. yada yada yada. All right. So, so
I says it very clearly that uh that the
that the mentioning of the Quran is in
the Torah and the Gospel and so does
Jalain. Well, it could if that's the
case then um I don't think that it would
be as as of a big surprise if that's not
mentioned like if that's not mentioned
in the Bible anymore. If you can find
that in the Bible that it is uh that
this Quran it is foretold in the
previous scriptures u because um I know
that you're going to agree with me if I
say that there are many things that have
been before in the Bible and now not
anymore. Yeah, I disagree with that.